the death of another horse at California
Santa Anita racetrack is raising new
safety concerns about the sport in
Saturday's six million dollar Breeders
Cup Classic the horse Mongolian groom
broke his left hind leg and had to be
euthanized this is Santa Anita's 37th
horse death since December Don Dahler is
in Arcadia California Don this problem
just keeps getting bigger it really does
in a horse racing deaths though are a
national problem it's not just here in
consistent track surfaces the use of
performance-enhancing drugs as well as
over racing horses all those things
contribute and the fact that there is a
lack of a uniform regulatory body that
has the advocates for reform even more
concerned the exciting Breeders Cup
races Racing's unofficial world
championships had gone smoothly until
Saturday's final race nearly 68,000 fans
cheered a stirring win but soon realized
that four-year-old Mongolian groom had
suffered a serious injury near the end
of the race track officials and
veterinarians rushed to the injured
horse but after consultation with
several vets Mongolian groom was
euthanized protestors gathered outside
the track yesterday demanding reforms
for the sport that sees an estimated two
or three times as many deaths in the US
as other countries after the race PETA
responded forcefully calling for the
suspension of all trainers and
veterinarians of horses who died pending
full investigations among other reforms
we really have to transform the way
we've been racing last week we spoke
with veterinarian Deon Benson who was
hired to oversee protocols at Santa
Anita after it voluntarily closed last
spring her team now aggressively
monitors horses before they race
overseas new medication restrictions and
is hoping to bring new technology to
scan for hidden injuries
additionally the track has a new
drainage system it hasn't stopped deaths
entirely but they have slowed the
research says something along the lines
of ten horses a week died at racetracks
around this country is that just a part
of the industry that people maybe who
don't follow horse racing just don't
underst
dan I don't know that you they need to
understand it I think we need to get
better I think that if we can get the
rest of the country on the same page as
we are here at Santa Anita we can
improve that number advocacy groups are
asking Congress to establish a national
racing authority to regulate things such
as track conditions as well as the use
of medicines on these horses Gail Thank
You Don